Elle était si jolie
Que je n'osais l'aimer
Je ne peux l'oublier
Elle était trop jolie
Quand le vent l'emmenait
Elle fuyait ravie
Et le vent me disait
"Elle est bien trop jolie
Et toi je te connais
L'aimer toute une vie
Tu ne pourras jamais"
Oui mais elle est partie
C'est bête mais c'est vrai
Elle était si jolie
Je n'oublierai jamais
Aujourd'hui c'est l'automne
Et je pleure souvent
Qu'il est loin, le printemps
Dans le parc où frissonnent
Les feuilles au vent mauvais
Sa robe tourbillonne
Puis elle disparait
Elle était si jolie
Que je n'osais l'aimer
Je ne peux l'oublier
Elle était trop jolie
Quand le vent l'emmenait
Elle était si jolie
Je n'oublierai jamais